[Music]
[Music]
stick
[Music]
i can't believe we had to resort to
eating carl
we've known since we were kids
i i know but
we we've been stuck in this bomb shelter
since the invasion
i know
i know
and you know what the worst part is
i'm not even full yet
me neither
i'm so hungry
let me grab my patriots supply
boom
what you've
you had that the entire time
yeah i forgot i bought it
like there's like 10 of them
we ate a human being we did
but now we have macaroni and cheese
and oatmeal
and
uh
ooh pancakes
and oh my favorite
pudding
this changes everything i love pudding
[Music]
hey carl
you want some
i guess not cuttings for a live people
only
i'm out i need yours
no give me oh i eat you
my patriot supply
delicious and a whole lot better than
eating carl
june 18th
pikes peak center
prepares
for the funniest show on
[Music]
i know i know you were but i got an idea
i got an opener for colorado springs
okay ready yep last time i was this high
i got checked into rehab
because it's high altitude are you doing
drugs again though
no
no like i'm on a high altitude oh okay
no
i think it's pretty solid
it needs something should i work on a
jerry garcia reference oh i like that
yeah timely timely all right
that might do drugs
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
hmm
delicious and i need to look at this
there you go my seat was a little bit
too high you're a tall fellow glad to be
with you hey look i uh i bring uh
i bring tidings of great joy today ah i
think that's how it's said i think so uh
because yesterday i know it was intense
with libs of tick tock by the way have
some announcements coming here soon uh
we love those guys support them uh but
today some good news some good news
netflix crashing
twitter have their they really have
their their uh their their their their
wiener and auger
uh disney crashing cnn plus you can
guess i mean i'll foreshadow but you
know
spoiler alert to crash yes
exactly
burning on the runway they overloaded
they overpassed their envelope like
rihanna's luggage yeah
a lot of batteries in the plane yes
a lot of batteries in samsonite so look
oops it's not all bad there are and i'm
not just talking politically so this is
what we're going to be talking about
today i'm not just talking about the red
wave that's going to be happening most
likely in the midterms if you do your
job sponsored by uh by kotex i'm not
just talking about political office i am
talking about culturally
you are not alone
and you're seeing this happen across the
board so it's going to be a fun show
i don't know that this one would get
removed but again if we're not on
youtube you don't see us if we haven't
told you we're not doing a show head on
over to rumble or head on to mug club
monday through thursday 10 a.m eastern
we are always streaming that's the best
way to find us if you search this show
and the title
you won't find it also if you're on
youtube hit the share button the share
button does help uh we're finding that
the algorithm now is changing sharing is
caring they're also changing the live
viewership algorithm oh really that's
good yeah just keep changing stuff oh we
got that here what's that the sharing is
carrying oh we don't know but that's
just uh we all we all agreed that that
was a little too gay yeah we need a
better one save it for june guys save it
for june so my uh here's my question
today and it's more of and by the way
we're going to be having competitions
we're going we're going to actually be
giving out uh
not only locks of gerald's
remaining here we're going to be it's
your body here we're also going to be
giving away merch that's signed that's
been used on the program and pin your
comments your best comments under each
video so today is actually a good day to
start give us give me your best pitch
for a awoke netflix movie or series get
in the mind of a liberal all right
good luck i don't know if there's
congratulations on the millions you're
about to make yes
and then lose yes yeah gerald a is here
how are you i'm doing better i guess a
minute ago than i am now because i'm
losing hair on your back well it's a
good trade-off right now it's it's it's
precious yeah well the last thing you
want to be is that guy who tries to get
the the plugs and then you go bald
anyway so you have the scar yeah so oh
that's yeah oh man thanks guys you made
two bad decisions uh and uh you know him
you love him he's actually going to be
at the uh funny bone in virginia beach
this saturday but him and i are in
colorado springs june 18th pikes peak
center there's
one there's we had to add another show
so there are tickets to that second show
uh june 18th
tulsa's sold out sorry sorry ahoy
hi dave
i didn't know where sorry i was trying
to plug all your stuff i know i didn't i
didn't know i thought i didn't know if
you were done i'm done it's better than
hair plugs are you good just it is
better than hair steve and i aren't
worried about that
oh what i worry about
you know
i'm sorry you have height
yeah want to trade i'll give you my hair
perfect area my hair for people to look
up at me yeah he's like straight from a
page of hitler youth well hitler senior
youth hitler scene yeah yeah he's not
not that old no not hitler youth you'd
be like hitler i'm younger than that
hitler writer midlife crisis yeah by the
way hitler happy birthday
is it his birthday today
yeah it's 4 20.
really i thought we would say
like his death
no no it's his birthday it's uh well i
guess we can celebrate it ironically
because he's dead well yeah well i
didn't really mean happy birthday hitler
hey by the way i don't know if you guys
know this
but a sponsor to our show
it's the gun that killed hitler oh there
you go yeah it is that's the ava braun
yes
the ava braun special the aver braun
millimeter now he could have gone out 40
years earlier i know at least 20. so
before we move on to all of the info
with netflix you know their stock price
is taking a dive and they're giving a
bunch of reasons as to why that's the
case
they're lying through their genderqueer
teeth but this is so let's lead with
this um they're now
about to add a new documentary and i
thought this was so interesting because
maybe they included in the documentary
but certainly not in the teaser a lot of
people don't know the history of
abercrombie and fitch but their teaser
is a full-on uh homoerotic uh
tableau
i warn if you have children
here i know we have a lot of gay fans if
you're you know be careful yeah be
careful we don't want to we don't want
to cause
yeah homo brother to stumble they just
walk into the store and look at the
pictures of the guys fighting in mud yes
that's always like how is this pants no
this is these are our new mud pants yes
ah yes there's so many shirtless dudes
tackling each other in shorts and you
would just think they would reverse it
yeah abercrombie like put the ladies in
the men's section put the man in the
women's section oh
your demographics so this is the netflix
teaser for their abercrombie documentary
you know that you're getting close when
you're hit with the smell of abercrombie
big nightclub beats
yes hair chested guys
it was such a pop culture phenomenon it
was all-american that's a guy's locker
i considered myself an all-american girl
[Music]
oh make me over
abercrombie and fitz said we go after
the cool kids
[Music]
if they didn't look a certain way they
didn't belong in our clothing
are we exclusionary
absolutely yeah because gay hipsters
wouldn't know anything about being
exclusionary no
and this is what good is like token
girls every once in a while
i'm just saying no one's wearing clothes
in your clothing except the girls the
girls are fully clothed a single level
there's a reason people like to that
brand
exclusion is part of our society
they work with so firing people on the
basis of their looks was that the eunuch
from game of thrones yes
we were being racially discriminated
against it was that we weren't good
looking enough
correct
they've literally made some modeling
happens
was the root of their success
[Applause]
they had a no head scarf policy
went all the way to the
court yes
all american doesn't mean all white
[Music]
certainly means
all know hijab we have some really
troubling behavior
this picture of four shirtless guys
tackling one in a he job somehow that's
supposed to look good
they didn't invent evil
they didn't invent class
they just packaged it
[Music]
okay all right well i have a couple of
things that i want to say here a couple
of things that i want to say first off
this also ignores look this is the
byproduct of post-modernism you think it
was conservatives who wanted a bunch of
shirtless models at the local mall no
look abercrombie was originally a gun
and western sportswear company a lot of
people don't know that so that's what it
was back when it was primarily aimed at
men and then you created the image of
the modern man and then you decided that
they wanted a bunch of shirts yeah look
at that the guy's got his uh was that a
britney spaniel look at this was
abercrombie he's not shirtless
and all the references are available at
lidarwithcrowder.com we'll have those
pictures up there a lot of people don't
know the history but it's funny to me
that they're sit first off the hijab
thing yeah this is a perfect example of
the media this is the disconnect wanting
you to be offended
it's sort of like with donald trump when
donald trump you would say something
like you know would i take any
immigrants from eddie boy [ __ ]
countries media can you believe that he
called them that and then people at home
are like i call them that all the time
yeah like this didn't offend us at all
they're like right here they're going
they didn't allow women to wear hijabs
well they also don't allow people to
wear shirts so it seems like we're two
steps removed
and it's exclusionary because i'm not as
good-looking as them
do you think that's what people used to
do like they used to look at audrey
hepburn's like you [ __ ] i can't
why don't why isn't it me no it wasn't
you because we like great beauty this is
why they're a statue you can go back to
any society for crying out loud you can
go back to the romans you can go back to
the greeks you can even go back to
caveman etchings on the wall it's just
stick figure with tits this is what we
have admired since the beginning of time
we don't expect it to be a realistic
depiction of us that's why they're
models
by the way the netflix thing it's just
highlighting the homoerotic stuff but
you remember the catalogs in like the
90s and 2000s of course i'm like eight
years old and my next-door neighbor she
has a 16 year old sister she's getting
these these cows are like this thick and
it's full of like male nudity but also
female nudity too delivered to a 16 year
old yeah i know it didn't always used to
be that it didn't always used to be that
way no but you ordered cargo pants and
hemp necklaces right they they sucked
yeah pretty much i mean everybody got
him though he's absolutely right
everything has to be a gay thing i like
gays abercrombie i had a sweater i used
to sweat a lot and i wanted to hide it
and it was furry sweater and sweatshirts
two different things i learned that yeah
one's wool
is it well i don't know i thought it
could be a nice acrylic but
the point is netflix uh we've got a
segment on you and uh you know what uh
maybe this is why
you deserve to die figuratively hope
there's an airbag at the bottom of that
cliff
yes and if there isn't you can actually
just tie a hijab into a bag and blow
there you go i'm just glad that all
white men have six packs i learned that
yes and those weird kind of v things
that i won't get into dave don't say it
i can't use the first word no the second
word is gutters yes
terrible two bic lines cubic lines yeah
yeah it's not you know what look six
packs are for uh they're for teenagers
and drug addicts so yeah they're not
real they're not you have to be it's
just not normal look this is a thing too
or people said that it's unrealistic
okay can we at least admit now
that none of us are one green smoothie
away from being justin bieber it applies
to both men and women there you go
you're not the only ones who feel like
you're being body shamed this has
happened across the board it's just that
guys don't have to get emotionally
invested and upset over it if we see
another good looking guy in a catalog we
go oh okay yeah good for him oh you know
the guy's probably on juice
we don't need to start a march we do
yeah
we come out with reasons why it's like
oh he probably doesn't have a family
he's of course you can work out yeah
yeah no dad bod jeez oh sorts of time on
your hands isn't that great
good for you didn't have that prolactin
release that occurs after having
children probably a jerk too yeah i just
don't you go into a place and there's
just hello comically homoerotic photos
everywhere and a dj i'm like wow this
feels like shopping yes
and someone's following you around and
spraying you with perfume whether you
want it or not
that's like you're being maced at a rave
yeah well what happened hey you go meet
up with your wife it's like i went to
abercrombie and fitch for five minutes i
came out gay and smelling like a spring
meadow i don't know how
yeah no this is my boyfriend he's a dg
at abercrombie and fitch he'd be like
get out of my house your beard honey you
have five seconds or i would lure him in
the house with a bunch of abercrombie
catalogs and then a shotgun tied to the
final door
knob
there's more in there
opens it up all right just in there
trust me your parents won't mind what
happens speaking of things that people
don't like
bill o'reilly uh is also trending the
saint
he was caught on tape now look i know
some people are gonna say hey
why look bill o'reilly is not one of us
he's never been one of us he's never
been a conservative i've worked at fox
news for four and a half years there's a
little bit of inside baseball that i
won't fully get into because i think
that's caddy and in that case i'd be a
model of abercrombie and fitch but
he was caught on tape uh harassing a
allegedly 72 year old jet blue worker
and there's there's some dynamics here
that do that do matter so we'll talk
about that after but here's a clip when
bill o'reilly's flight was delayed
[Music]
three hours later
you're gonna find out
yeah you're gonna find out lower level
employees
[Music]
i was listening on audio he called him
an effing scumbag
why was there a sexual harassment claim
right
[Applause]
did they have you on tape
and by the way with some bill o'reilly
stuff
yes
it happened it's not one of those me too
they happened long before me too
happened uh you know i worked at fox for
bill o'reilly did actually i think you
want to be on this show and uh so
have us on me on his show so he could be
on this show i was like do you know what
i've said yeah
um it's gonna be awkward i worked at fox
for four and a half years and the rule
was if you gave something to handed to
you didn't appear on bill o'reilly and
vice versa so it was you know a 21 year
old being used like a human ping-pong
ball and i did have stuff ripped off
from me uh
i've never had any personal negative
interactions with bill o'reilly and
there was one producer there who was
really nice named ron every other
interaction i had with the program was
really crappy and everyone said the same
thing
and there's a lifetime of footage you
can see with bill o'reilly the problem
here this is a guy
who
and you get this with also it's very
similar to liberal elitists nancy pelosi
insider trading they get to a point um
where they're on this pedestal they're
so out of touch with reality and then
when they get knocked off they still
think they can behave the way that they
could on that pedestal and so he's
treating people like crap as he's always
treated people like crap like his
producers like his assistants like the
women who worked for him when he would
try and read erotica over the phone and
they weren't even willing participants
are you still there yeah i'm still here
still listening to her yep she's just
doing the dishes yeah yes yeah keep
talking this is crazy i bet you just
he's not used to flying commercial and i
honestly i can't believe he has to fly
jet blue
yeah didn't have spirit there's not even
a classic system on that no see i was
supposed to be at a sex island hours ago
and now my generic viagra is wearing off
i'm not even gonna be hard when i land
if the pilot's not running down i'm
gonna slap his james brown wig clean off
are there still stewardesses i can grope
what do you mean they're mostly men now
were they just stewards are they just
named stewart at that point
i'm up i'm i'm upset because i might
have taken too much
ritural gas station boner medicine and
mini fins
you have to fix this day raider
i've been working around the clock on a
new book that people will pick up at
this very airport take one glance at and
immediately set back down with no
intention of purchasing it yes it's
titled killing jetblue airlines
employees yes my gosh
killing jesus killing lincoln killing it
was killing the killers was the name of
one of his books was it really yeah it's
like you need to give up yeah he's
focusing on killing quite a bit yep well
yeah now he's killing the asian guy
who's just trying to do his job yeah
killing your own career that's exactly
it and he he said on twitter and this is
why i think it's important to
differentiate because look we don't have
all of the details and i get that you
can get frustrated with airline
employees and i get that they can get a
little bit lippy yeah
but
still this does seem like it's out of
line and let's not conflate this with
the kind of cultural censorship the kind
of cultural marxism that some people
refer to as cancel culture uh
with what's happened here bill riley he
tweeted this out uh the charac the
character assassins on social media
completely lying about my interaction
with a jet blue guy who misled
passengers during a five-hour delay
we've covered on billaraly.com i
expected this
uh
wow
so
by the way how do you know
how do you know that they misled you
this is the question right we'll be
talking actually with half asian lawyer
bill richmond about johnny depp yeah and
uh by the way just spoiler alert amber
heard is a piece oh crap yes oh yes just
awful i not even a johnny depp fan
because every character that he plays
just becomes a creepy gay character he's
like will he want a creepy game we want
a pirate creepy gay pirate uh
scissor hands creepy gay says her hands
chad i don't mind the indie work but
it's definitely the barber creepy gay
barber okay yeah every single thing
creepy gay wizard creepy gay creepy gay
fantastic beasts guy yeah the cream and
barber of meat street yes
but this is a but the the the the sort
of metrics right that need to be met or
the bars that need to be met for example
for defamation which is what he's suing
amber heard for you need to be able to
prove that someone lied you need to be
able to prove that someone knowingly
lied you know either lied negligently
with a public figure that means with
malicious intent you need to be able to
prove that there were serious
reputational damages i think johnny depp
clears all of them but in this case he
goes
this person deliberately misled us
how do you know he deliberately misled
you
how do you know that employee
deliberately misled you and i will say
this this is why as you go through your
day-to-day life you do have to give
people the benefit of the doubt so that
when you do react
when there is righteous rage and there
is such thing as righteous rage
righteous indignation then people know
that it's appropriate that you've
removed dull doubt if you give people
the benefit of the doubt
once you flip the switch you remove all
doubt but bill o'reilly just does this
all the time i mean who would have
thought that this guy who would have
thought that this guy could ever scream
at some lower level employee to make his
point
that's tomorrow and that is it for us
today
okay i don't know
whatever it is it's not right on the
teleprompter i don't know what that is
i've never seen that
no there is we are going to do sting
yeah okay but
now i can't read it there's no there's
no words on it
okay
right
there's no words there to play us out
what does that mean to play us out how
does that know that
this thing is going to do it's a video
sting video
to play us out what does that mean
to end the show yeah
[Music]
all right go go in five four three
that's tomorrow and that is that
again
still funny that's tomorrow and that is
it for us today and we will leave you
with a
uh i can't do it
we'll do it live okay
no we'll do it live [ __ ] it
do it live i can i'll write it and we'll
do it live
[ __ ] thing sucks
he has to do it watch that's tomorrow
that's about it for us today i'm bill
o'reilly thanks again for watching we'll
leave you with sting and a cut off his
new album take it away
now watch here he whips his
i've cut the there's no
[Laughter]
i just love that he has to go right back
into it it sucks and that's tomorrow
sting level cut off of his new album
you're all gonna burn
he's gonna play us out what the hell
does that mean yeah i don't know how he
didn't know that
yeah that's what
happened on this show this is the game
even if i was hosting i'd be like well i
just i'll just say what was there yeah
and i just said people can get
frustrated like you kind of heard with
with christian bale where a guy was he
apologized but i understand if you're
trying to do an emotional scene and
someone's screwing around yeah well
there's the plus the heat the
repetitions that's right tedious i get
that you have to get emotionally intense
for scenes but in this case he just
needed to say uh here's a cut from sting
to play us out i don't think that that
requires so much buy-in that you know
you have to be in the zone there's no
words yeah it's really only tedious
because of you right i only know how to
speak when there are words for me on the
screen
and f.u san diego yes
yeah he's just somebody still feels
important not a fan all right no he's
one of the folks hey by the way guys
smash that like button if you're
watching on youtube we're about to talk
uh netflix and uh they're not gonna like
this look out below it's always weird
this is the kind of thing with with bill
o'reilly it's always weird when you talk
about something and you know that the
people that are watching
because you know the people at netflix
are watching kind of like youtube when
we would get a call or you know you make
fun of some senator then they're
bitching on the bitching on the floor at
some hearing you're like it was a goof
hirono again i never expected to
be this influential
so i know that someone at netflix just
like someone at youtube who bought our
mystery box years ago oh that's with the
band merchandise was furious uh we'll be
back it'll be back only popular demand
only at live events live shows if you go
to pikes peak colorado you can buy the
uh the old socialism fake shirt but we
will not sell it anywhere online
so netflix whichever one of you is
watching i don't know if you're the ceo
or the patsy for the higher ups
uh they just released a q1 earnings
report yesterday yeah numbers not
looking great that's saying
yeah saying it nicely now um here's the
thing they have a bunch of reasons as to
why
i don't buy them
but i think maybe it could be partially
partially not entirely i don't want to
be reductive partially because of gems
like these
life down on earth can be very
complicated and that's why people need
us
your team members will be hormone
monsters our divisions orgasm numbers
just came in and corporate is [ __ ]
pissed shame wizard good call mentioning
a knockout her sister is in your wedding
test logic rocks there's no reason to
stand up yet i promise you you will get
off the plane and
many more you'll be assigned your human
clients by the tube
oh it's for
me i'm sorry her
emmy what we do here is important
i get it i don't take notes i don't pay
attention i lied about my military
service
hi
i'm emmy your new love bug
[Music]
yeah how much do i have to watch of this
maybe like ten more seconds that's ten
seconds too many
crying grieving i just wanted to
pointless exercises and self-indulgence
oh i'm sorry are we still alive yes you
got it
love lesson number one
love is a
psycho
[Music]
this is way more than 10 seconds
thank you here's another one of the
popular kids
bring back the other one please she used
to be i don't mind rebel wilson no i
don't either i think she look at she
she was very big she worked very hard
this party is so we can be free without
prejudice or rules only for the brave
no
exactly
i think he
different this is a cargo shorts
commercial forever
looks like someone has a crutch
cindy's back on the block oh yeah she's
back
she's back and she's going hard
i got some good news that's just
tangerine it's the first movie shot on
an iphone
it is it is trans i know what it is
you didn't know
they're like six years late to this i
know
how long is this going to be do we have
to watch any more of this nice five
seconds they said that a minute ago a
minute ago i'm sorry viewers this we
should have done a better job with this
there's also cuties and there's also
basically everything is is is woke
elderly
i just i started watching the first
episode of the jimmy savile documentary
on there last night and i don't think i
can go to episode two no i've canceled
my subscription what would i say there
was another tangerine that came out that
same year and my dad had seen it he told
me to watch it so i looked up that
trailer and i was like what oh it was a
different name what is wrong with you
dad oh
dad yeah it was the first movie shot
yeah on an iphone and it was still
sucked that yeah you could definitely
shoot a film on an iphone yeah that's
neither here nor the point
oh no i'm not saying that that makes it
good no but netflix is seeing a stock
note so let me give you a little bit of
info like i said there's some good news
and then even jack dorsey but wow i'm
not saying that what jack dorsey has
done is you know at this point
forgivable no first off because he's an
ask for forgiveness second because he's
a demon still has the beard yes yeah uh
netflix they just lost nearly 200 000
subscribers since the end of uh q4 that
means the fourth quarter for people and
i just don't know that's their first
loss
of subscribers in a decade wow they were
expecting
two million new subscribers two and a
half two and a half yeah i was rounding
down because i just thought i didn't
need to add insult to injury they missed
it by like over 2.7 million yes they did
that's pretty close
and they expect to lose another two
million global subscribers this quarter
ah that's pretty big no you should give
the same eight comic specials overnight
yes exactly
i need another hannah gatsby yeah please
i can't wait to feel bad i'm still
laughing from the first two
self-deprecation is self-humiliation and
i won't do it we'll find just tell us
what you will do not jokes uh-huh just
do the humiliation please a bit of this
harry potter who's eaten too much
frosting yes
i'm true kerry before he lost weight yes
so the news uh of netflix they're stocks
the prices of food right i'm sorry no
their stock um is 37 lower compared to
yesterday oh what a difference 37 lower
is not a mundane detail michael yeah and
uh over the last six months it's down 61
yeah a high of seven hundred dollars a
share to not even close to that today
yeah
well that's insane i just wanted i
wasn't sure if my ira had gotten lower
and by the way this is despite them
still being the uh i don't know if you
know this they're still the world leader
in uh dvd uh blu-ray rental they still
uh the dvd service still has 2 million
subscribers
are you serious people still do that yes
you said this before the show yes they
do kidding so what i would advise is not
only cancel your subscriptions uh but
also have them ship out dvds and send
them immediately back so there's no way
they could keep up with the shipping
costs so
totally legal
totally watch their two million dvd
subscribers go to three million tomorrow
we can't keep up with this tv this is
too expensive
it's all your fault now they immediately
went on the defensive because they had
to and they claimed that there were four
interrelated factors and that's by the
way that's tech industry talk for uh
[ __ ] so uh this is how they explain
their their poor performance they said
uh number one it's a lack of broadband
accessibility well that doesn't work
because guess what it's not like
broadband is less accessible than before
it wouldn't explain the trend number two
they said password sharing please please
put on a a password sharing lock like
they're talking about that's one of the
only reasons that people use netflix
what they're actually listing are
reasons that should
support more subscribers yeah people
would subscribe with more password
sharing people would be subscribing more
because there is continually more access
to broadband right there's more and more
affordable number three they were saying
new competition well that's true and
then number four macro factors like
inflation inflation russia's invasion of
the ukraine come on how is russia's
invasion of the ukraine having it this
is this is putin's economy
although 90 of it happened a while ago
now i do think that is true though i do
think people are probably cutting back
so i'll give them that one but what
about this i would list a couple of
reasons netflix how about the increasing
price
[Music]
while also decreasing the quality of
content i think that's a big deal think
about this for a second their shows suck
yeah most of them suck they lost all the
marvel stuff that was a big component of
it and not to mention uh of course
all the wokeness all of it look that
you've seen a lot of people cancel their
netflix subscriptions we'll get to
disney in a second cnn plus this is a
trend across the board specifically with
companies that have decided to bet it on
a political point of view yeah and they
deserve this yes they absolutely do this
is the market winning out that's why
we're this is a win for everybody out
there it's not just saying oh boycott
this do that it's like no just just vote
with your dollars your boycott and your
buy cut and by the way mug club lot of
credit dot com club it's 69 for students
veterans active military we have not
seen a drop now that again we don't have
uh how many hundreds of millions of
subscribers but the point is we still
see the same trend because you join and
you stay and we try to provide value
added like today we'll be playing bad
movie lines which we can never play on
youtube here's another thing
uh elon musk even mentioned and chimed
in on this uh what it might be and he uh
he tweeted out uh or i believe yeah he
tweeted he said the woke mind virus is
making netflix unwatchable that's a
south african environmentalist folks
82.5 million followers right well and
he's absolutely right that's the problem
is when you start going at social media
and thinking that that is the only
barometer of what people want to watch
this is what happens right this is
exactly you create a bunch of content
that no one wants right yeah you think
cuties which is basically just for who
porn it's for nobody though yeah it's
not for nobody it's for public school
yeah but even the stuff you try to make
for the people you think you're going to
please hate you anyway yeah those
pedophiles are notoriously difficult
consumers
yeah they are very different they're
very persnickety with their child
pornography i guess with cuties they may
have hit the mark perfectly i just mean
with the other program yeah i started
watching i thought i was going to be
about clementines
yeah that's tangerine
so uh he didn't stop there though here's
the thing with elon elon is actually
doubling down he's giving context to it
he uh responded with some other tweets
that were aimed at him um this guy uh
pat hole tweeted woke my virus is the
biggest threat to civilization and elon
responded yes niche gamer tweeted not
just netflix movies in general video
games tv it's all infested with the
current year trend woke garbage for fear
of offending green haired freaks next to
the band button and elon replied true
uh and i think he deleted some of those
tweets because he may have been drunk
but he was correct right that just
doesn't matter not all drunk texts are
wrong no especially well i think drunken
aspergers are probably even more
accurate yeah exactly yeah 3 10 in the
morning 3 16 in the morning no he works
at night have you ever read anything
about this guy come on
he works all night he also works at day
i have to write something down here
because i forgot something so a
millionaire
he's a psycho yeah it's awesome i mean i
don't know if he's a psycho in a good
way he's a genius like a sociopath in a
in a good way uh asperger's right not a
bad one no like just uh
he can count like matchsticks
or toothpicks yeah he's a dustin hoffman
yes exactly yeah like i'd go down an
elevator with them in a match so would i
but i wouldn't turn on the i wouldn't
turn on the bathwater
[Music]
[Laughter]
so um
why would elon think mr musk thinks that
netflix is woke and we just showed you a
montage but let me kind of rattle off a
couple here uh content like he's
expecting
dear white people we the people cuties
13th growing up koi welcome to leaf
the mask you live in this is the thing
so yeah he's expecting is
i mean you would have we would have
written that as a joke as a joke movie
title i could think of as the kevin
bacon movie it's like he's having a baby
right i think of junior junior yeah yeah
here's the arnold schwarzenegger now
it's woke yeah i couldn't do missed out
fire nowadays hate speech oh absolutely
and it's not just netflix oh hold on a
second oh they're talking about it right
now on cnn hey oliver darcy world's most
world's most useless professional
wow but there are a lot of other things
that play here too is he wearing a mask
nose disguise i think so
amongst each other
yeah like ben kingsley and gandhi yeah
wearing a jokestore face
thirty-five percent
wow
let's okay let's hear what they have to
say let's see if they admit
because we're about to get the cnn plus
two so look at all ties in let's see if
they admit as to why maybe they're
seeing a hit 21 million uh subscribers
netflix has now the idea is that netflix
is going to keep growing and growing and
maybe the market's a billion subscribers
or something like that but you're seeing
netflix stall now and actually lose
subscribers so it's it's really making
wall street rethink the business model
um of netflix and other streaming
companies and so what you're seeing is
major jitters uh netflix's stock price
you know it's down 60 percent uh this
year and 35 percent alone today it's one
of the worst days ever on six months
more in netflix
since this year
i won my team you just saw that
admonish him
have cnn on air and admonish him he's
wrong do you see that
see that he said years six months
not wanting users this year no he said
this year which would mean just over
three months three and a half months or
so it's like that's not true where a
jury has just acquitted a dollar that's
it think about that that's why and we'll
get to cnn plus in a second why would
anyone subscribe he just delivered the
info that we delivered to you beforehand
yeah
in a more slow way in a more
uninteresting way and he didn't provide
the why he didn't provide any insight
now let's not act like it's because he's
simply delivering the news because
oliver darcy constantly delivers the y
he constantly paints it with his opinion
of brush what happened here today is
they didn't really want to get into why
because it might also reflect poorly on
cnn which brings me to before scene and
disney disney their stock fell five
percent today in pre-market trading yes
uh in six months
twenty-five percent that's how they've
dropped almost 26 25
and just to be clear this is something
all references are available at
lyderworthcredor.com this is something
that i try and do
with you guys is try and give you apples
to apples comparison why because i did
work at fox news for years and you see
this on cnn where what they do is
they'll say this year it's only it's
down this amount and then compare it to
where is this and they take two quarters
or they take q3 i'm trying to give you
six months and today for netflix and
disney so you have what the drop was
today and you have a six month snapshot
i think that's important to do so in the
day of taylor lorenz and people talking
about common journalistic practices i
don't know why consistent metrics aren't
included there but i see it all the time
you just saw it there on cnn so uh you
know you can we've already admonished
him so disney five percent today 25
uh over six months now there are many
technical reasons for uh the drop in
disney but alienating half of its
audience
and by the way most notably half of that
audience being the governor of florida
that's a really bad move by the way
might be a component and they're they're
really pissed off about that so desantis
is actually reviewing the special like
tax status that they have uh and that
could cost them tens of millions of
dollars every single year it's like what
are you gonna do build your theme park
somewhere else fine close it down and go
we'll use the land for something else
yeah leave the rides right yeah where
are they gonna go where's it gonna be
more friendly yeah build a disney world
next to disneyland in california and by
the way people saying oh this is
inconsistent no aoc for example kept
amazon out yes the average salary was
over six figures and the citizens
overwhelmingly wanted it and uh she just
didn't like them to have tax incentives
yeah they didn't want they don't have
when you're recruiting businesses you
give them tax incentives to make them
come there provide jobs the local
economy grows everybody makes more money
and they end up paying a bunch of taxes
anyway right they just pay a little bit
less that's how you get businesses to
move there in florida they gave them
this provision i think back in the 60s
and if they don't renew it they're going
to just let it expire and start
collecting more money and saying look if
you want to do stuff to destroy our
state to destroy our culture we're not
and not only keep in mind it's also
disney working with companies that are
not in florida other people you know
flooding much political money flooding
in being matched by disney from places
like new york from places like
california to try and punish the
citizens of florida who agree with the
bill that you shouldn't sexualize uh you
know teachings to k through three
five-year-olds six-year-olds you know
take your picture in fairness to aoc
the area where they are going to build
that is now terrible and most of the
restaurants are closed
so her plan worked come on she kept her
people in poverty aoc sooner or later
those gentrifying bastards had to pay am
i right right come on who wants to make
money hey what are what can i ask you
this genuinely
what are white people supposed to do
all right you say okay if we if if we
leave it's white flight if we move in
it's gentrification what are we supposed
to do what do you want
what do you want us to do die
it's a perfect example of simply of
racial hatred
no it is it's well if we move too far
it's like oh would you go to the country
because we're not around
yeah it's like oh yeah that's our fault
yes we left and that's why the area got
terrible hey i'm coming in bringing in
coffee shops like you know this area
isn't the same it's uh you're
gentrifying it all right i guess i'll
just go oh you're white flooding us now
what it's like i'm in a relationship
with with a crazy woman yeah and then
the white hipsters move back into the
area and it gets worse and we're like we
can't win yeah there's an epidemic of
hipster rape surprise
yeah sorry yep like detroit's moving and
you're like well it's getting pretty
nice yeah that's absolutely true hell's
kitchen
no more summer of sam when the uh
when the homosexuals moved in so
uh finally outside of the enter it
doesn't just affect entertainment
uh like disney netflix it also affects
non-entertainment
like cnn plus
they're also trending down
they invested 100 million dollars to
launch the streaming service at the
beginning of this month yes currently it
has 150 000 subscribers please invest
100 million more cnn it just takes one
more time yes yes no seriously look look
i do
i don't like cnn but i do like to see
people do well i'm a free enterpriser
yeah uh
cnn look
okay we're gonna
right let's put our guns down okay
i'm gonna offer you
it just requires more money
that's it you just you're not spending
enough just put more money put stealth
money in there put more money into it i
think stelter is at least ten thousand
of the subscribers yes
oh my gosh a hundred investors
just watching the cooking shows now
here's the thing
this is also the media disconnect here
look um
this is this has been we've lived
through a season when people talk about
movie stars when people look it's not
real when people talk about anchors it's
not real okay cnn mug club
it's this
just you subscribing for the show not
even including all of you who are there
at the blaze uh is more than all of
cnn's
prime time hosts combined doing their
cnn plus so once these people of course
get salaries of many many millions of
dollars per year i don't the salary of
an anderson cooper is more than the
total budget
many times over that we have for
employee staff utilities but when
they're on their own and they eat what
they kill and it's not some network when
you get to pay a la carte
you don't want them no what who's paying
extra
for more don lemon
joe lewis place more people would tune
in to joe lewis than joe lewis
see even i say don lemony doesn't like
it no one's saying needs more lemon no
there's i'm surprised there's 150 000
people willing to subscribe to more of
that by the way are you surprised people
just tuned in to joe lewis just now yes
just now all right thank you
joe lewis down chris wallace made a
great move huh left
fox to go to cnn plus right as it was
crashing so he jumped onto a sinking
ship that's that's usually the opposite
well people all bitched about we saw
this or bitching about cable and oh this
is going to fracture everything well
yeah it does so what happened is we had
three networks
viewership was crazy high then we went
to cable and everything sort of went
down again then we went to the stream
especially once we hit that point where
more people were unplugging and the big
shows that came back were like the
stranger things where now you basically
had three main networks at one point it
was like netflix hulu amazon prime
almost went back to exclusively network
tv now there are so many we're getting
back to the online fracturing and people
value their dollar more so when you get
to pay that's a good thing for you we'll
never have another johnny carson we'll
never have the kind of even like suit
well maybe the super bowl is one
exception but the oscars ratings yeah or
a late night show i mean you're talking
about a difference between 30 40 million
with carson and one of these other late
night shows is lucky to get three yeah
lucky to get three
but that's because you have more choice
and when you make your choice rather
than it being thrust into your
television sets guess what it doesn't do
well and that's why social media big
tech they're trying to thrust it into
your timelines only instead of calling
it a a cable package they're now calling
it an algorithm because these people
cannot win
and i mean don lemon cannot win no one
really cares what he has to say no one
wants to watch his content chris cuomo
cannot win anderson cooper cannot win
brian stelter cannot win so they have to
go to the powers that be and demand that
competition be eliminated you're seeing
that happen right now with netflix with
cnn with disney this is the only way
that they can succeed
and this is why so many people are
afraid of twitter being bought by
somebody who values free speech right
yeah they won't just shove these things
into your time oh and by the way you saw
this at the uh onset of the show yeah uh
sponsor for us uh uh it's uh my patreon
supply can go to prep with crowder.com
you get fifty dollars off a four week
emergency food kit they have um they
have so many five-star ratings look
there's one of those things i'm not like
some doomsday prepper just so you know
but do you remember what happened with
kovid have you seen the grocery store
shelves i lived through the ice storm we
couldn't get any food for about two
weeks it's just always a good idea to
have some some food ready and some water
and uh it's inexpensive and i got to
tell you
hey uh patriot supply and it's prep with
crowder.com um can you guys send me more
pudding i just uh
i hadn't done a grocery run
by the way
don't eat cards by the way that's not a
joke patriots
i don't need any more boxes but there is
i have no more pudding steven will eat
dave if you don't send more pudding
that's the mess stop joking they think
they're gonna think this is a joke it's
not a joke i've run out of pudding not a
joke and by the way it took a lot for me
to come out and say that it took a lot
for me to come out and say that because
it's embarrassing yeah it is give an
idea how embarrassing it is for me to
wake up in a puddle of my own filth and
then scrounge through my bomb shelter
food for pudding because i just
it's delicious i do but i need more
eating i'm out i'm legitimately out of
the pudding keep putting not dave all
right yes
so
uh you both while we're talking about
this uh we're talking about uh well
we'll talk about johnny depp with my
half-assing lawyer here i think maybe
next week and sort of uh go through that
case by case uh
here's let me set this up ezra miller i
didn't really know a whole lot about him
other than he's on one of those uh
superhero shows that i wouldn't watch
better than and he's non-binary i guess
he does this non-binary flash in the dc
universe and he was just arrested again
at 1 30 am oh
on tuesday and according to the police
ezra became quote irate after being
asked to leave and reportedly through a
chair striking a 26 year old female on
the forehead resulting in an approximate
half inch cut this is his second arrest
in three weeks oh no
he's been the reason for over 10 police
calls since march 7th
2022. here's some just and i have a
point that i want to mention why are you
talking about ezra miller that's
dave's like wow that beat my record by
far it's not even close we actually have
some videos of uh his other poor social
boundaries
you learn it did you want to fight
i don't know what he says here but watch
this it's like a cartoon
bro i'm sorry i don't we're not like
your outfit it seems sick and here's the
speed yours is pretty cool it's smooth
seems safe and breathable so what's the
point to this uh
gays non-binary people get away with
murder every time that i hear someone
say oh he was bullied for being gay in
high school uh
maybe if this was 1992 today all that's
required is a gay person say he said a
slur and that person's life is
absolutely destroyed because i'm gay you
can behave incredibly poorly
ten police calls two arrests and guess
what i don't know he hasn't been fired
whereas johnny depp was allegedly
falsely accused of abuse with no proof
from amber heard proof to the opposite
by the way that she was actually beaten
on him
and he loses everything he loses the
biggest role in modern franchise history
this is the pro so
let's not act as though the victim class
is actually the victim class at this
point when you represent
disproportionately
all of the programming on netflix and
four out of five hosts on cnn plus and
they all behave like crap it's not
because you're gay it's because you're
an [ __ ] right the thing you like well
the video you just showed it just is uh
it shows the completed mission of guilt
yes where the pictures amber heard took
where it was like yeah he was uh snow
snorting cocaine with my tampon
applicator i put here right while he
wasn't home right yeah clearly it
doesn't work that way
yeah everything that everything that she
did she's like this is his breakfast
it's like three beers and some lines as
his breakfast right
it's not accurate i mean look it's cool
but it's not true
right don't do that kid no no don't do
no it's of course you want to be the
cool kid you really can't have it for
breakfast guys i mean it's there's no
news unless you want to be a champion
yeah exactly unless you want to eat carl
three lines of coke have been on my
training table since i was a kid i'm on
the box of
wheat coke
now
my think about this so this is a this is
a consistent pattern you've seen it with
well we saw this with uh when we had to
deal with vox you saw it with jesse
smallett remember people at cnn
subscribe to cnn plus by the way juicy
uh
they were they were believing him they
said this is horrible i can't believe
this right because if someone is part of
the victim class you automatically
believe them and we saw that with the
metoo movement right because there's a
hierarchy well women and men and then if
there's a gay black man well you don't
necessarily know what to do it depends
on who is at the top of the food chain
that day this guy is committing actual
crimes this guy is a d
he's he's nothing but a disrupter to
society and they don't have to be held
accountable he's a degenerate they do
not have to be held accountable we
actually did this as an experiment a
long time ago with one of my producers
where we were in a mall and i said the
exact same thing as a a gay person so i
would say you have a really pretty smile
and they'll get creeped out you would
say you have a really you have pretty
smelly like oh thank you like i just
want to eat you up thank you i just want
to roll you up in a carpet and put you
in my trunk and drive you away and no
one will ever see you again like oh wow
they didn't do anything
they were about to punch you and mace
you because everyone is afraid to speak
out against someone who is more of a
protected class than themselves for fear
of losing their livelihood that's not a
good place to be look if it's a straight
white male who's a good guy
and a gay actor on a show that i've
never seen but a prick you want the
straight white male to point it out
regardless of whether this guy likes
being a rump ranger it could not be less
relevant
to the behavior this is one thing too
that you know people always say uh well
you know don't judge me because no no
people shouldn't people do judge you
though based on your behavior people
don't judge you based on your thoughts
that's the thing if you're gay fine
no no one here is saying that there's
that
you you don't have the right to be gay
or it needs to be illegal no one's
saying that but you're judged on your
behavior and if you're gay and your
behavior happens to be terrible
you're being judged on your behavior not
your sexual preference but unfortunately
that's not allowed
yeah you're right well it removes all of
the self-policing that we've done
forever right we've kept ourselves in
line up until now we're like well i
can't say anything he might be gay
i don't care i can't tell you i don't
know whether to say
ma'am or something i have no idea now
i'm just going to stay over here yeah
well someone tried to blame me for um
it's a transgender suicide
someone tried to send me like they sent
me like an email what oh
it was it was because of what you said
about have you watched the two genders
changed my mind have you watched it's
we've had angry lesbians sit down i'm
the only one who's been assaulted by the
way i do believe there are only two
genders because there have always only
been two genders i know you want to say
sex and gender but you can't you can't
say that anymore because now you have
men competing women's sports which is
separated from biological sex and you
can change your sex and your driver's
license so guess what sex and gender are
one and the same scientifically there
are two genders so you may not like it
don't blame me for a suicide there's
going to be a 41 chance they attempted
it anyway
well and the reality was suicide is
somebody's head in my family and
somebody who's you know considered
highly it cannot be blamed on one person
right that is an entire lifelong problem
of depression and other things being
untreated it's it's just grossly
irresponsible to go oh they kill
themselves and that's your fault no it's
not and you're completely you're
completely disregarding their entire
life by saying something so asinine yeah
but if i kill myself i'm gonna write my
suicide note that it was uh brian
stelter well yeah well then that would
be true
that's more to destroy him well yeah
i'll be like i just couldn't live up to
the beauty i just couldn't
i felt like i felt like no matter how
hard i tried he was always one step
ahead yeah i looked at the subscribers
and i just couldn't do it he was always
one deep footprint ahead there's always
one shower chair ahead of this
so this brings us to our so netflix look
this is good news yeah this is good news
there are changes that are taking place
it's not all bad this and the only way
you get good news is if you fight like
hell yesterday was a war day with libs
of tick tock we're gonna have some good
news on that front too
it's always good to sell celebrate the
wins
so smash the like button if you want to
celebrate the wins uh okay here's
another oh there you go call that the
party button yeah
party
i like to partay man so
uh jack dorsey now we just sort of hit
on this yesterday but now there's more
context to it um he's leaving twitter
you know yeah next month he's he's
he's yeah
but going scorched earth now
let me be clear and then i want to ask
you guys why you think this is because
it it could just be that this guy wants
his golden parachute with elon musk uh
he's stepping down from being he did
step down by the way from being ceo i
think it was in november yeah of 2021
yeah last year yeah you guys will have
the references i i think it's november
2021 uh and he's going to make a full
exit okay before leaving though he's
decided to uh go absolute ape
stuff yeah on the board of directors
there we go
that sounds like a new software program
aps
so
for those of you who don't know this
elon muskrat wanted to buy twitter so he
got he got a nine percent stake the
largest stick then he said you know what
i will offer you uh significantly above
the market price purchase all of it
which kind of put them in a bind because
then elon musk said and if you don't
then i'll have to reconsider my stake in
twitter which would cause their stock to
take a nosedive of course right so
twitter's board of directors
they recently adopted what would be
described as a poison pill to prevent
elon musk's potential takeover which
screws everybody screws everybody's any
share of twitter ever exactly
now keep in mind this is also when
people say like oh these corporations
are just beholden to their shareholders
i think there is a problem with that too
sometimes with publicly traded companies
uh if they cut corners right or if it
ends up harming the consumer if they
place the shareholders value above the
consumer that being said i would
certainly rather these companies right
look out for the best interest of their
shareholders than ideologues on the
board so let's be clear about that kind
of like when people say corporate media
man i get it there are problems with it
that's why this is entirely independent
but
the alternative where i was raised cbs
you want government media so let's just
try and put this in context um
two notable figures okay uh government
media i didn't mean interrupt you cbc
yeah canada yeah is it really yeah it's
government funded and as a matter of
fact if i'm not mistaken maybe the
research guys you know guys you can pull
this up i don't remember the exact
numbers i think one of the people
running for prime minister it might have
been the ndp said that if he won he
would give the cdc a hundred million
dollars more in funding and i think it
was trudeau who said yeah but if i win
i'll give you uh 150 million he was
doing black facebook yeah of course 150
million and guess who they gave
favorable
i like kids in the hall on and i'm
surprised they allowed that yep yep a
lot of people don't realize that cbc is
largely government-funded and then you
have this in a lot of different uh
countries okay and that's scarier look
at least corporate at least when people
point to fox news the reason fox news
has all of these great rating is because
it's the only one from that point of
view yeah
it's the reason we have the ratings that
we do compared to other other
entertainment shows i mean it's really
more comfortable to a late night show it
was a late night show but then we
realized that most of you actually work
so you watch it in the morning so it's
like late night in the morning but it's
because this is the only one that hasn't
officially endorsed hillary clinton and
joe biden right so you have a wide open
lane that's a good thing to have that
competition at least
so let's just be aware here when people
say shareholders okay would you rather
twitter screw the shareholders which is
what they're willing to do now to look
out for the ideological preferences
of the board before you answer
most of the people on that board are
pieces of [ __ ] so
uh
two notable figures in the tech industry
they pointed out uh the toxicity of a
lot of these you know boards and how
terrible they can be to which jack
dorsey responded big facts hmm
not many words but big bells that
actually seems like a donald trump yeah
that is a big fact
[Laughter]
[Applause]
someone's
huge yeah someone said ted cruz's dad
killed jfk facts thanks
i wouldn't say big fats
true facts
[Laughter]
um one twitter user actually described
the board at twitter as being quote
mired in plots and coups from the
beginning and then dorsey added it's
consistently been the dysfunction of the
company yeah and uh here's the thing
dorsey isn't just doing this with the
board so this is when people i think
there is a shift with dorsey but i i'm
not saying that he's done so much damage
to our society yeah we'll get to that i
mean the new york post right what
they've done on twitter uh to whom
they've catered so i'm not saying that
this absolves him of those sins no
absolutely not
but the why is an interesting
conversation that we'll have here as to
uh he's he's made this change so he also
went after cnn's um super straight super
super straight and cnn plus his mega
star brian selter yes
stelter tweeted tucker carlton is always
selling the same thing and philip bump
says he's selling doubt
he's selling doubt
why do you doubt my sexuality
what are you selling i'm super straight
girl scout cookies just kidding buying
them though yes that's why i have my
purse it's a gym bag yeah see my name
was the last time you saw the inside of
a gym that's not important right now
wait like a guy or a gym
[Laughter]
so he said uh he's he's selling doubt
dorsey quipped
and you are all selling hope yeah what
so he's so he's seeking himself here
secretly based over here and uh stelter
must have felt uh the impending uh the
impending heterosexual doom because he
offered dorsey an interview ah
ah very nice boy look at those two side
profiles that's the same species folks
that is hard to believe
is one song imagine that in biology
so the man has a weight range of 120 to
412 pounds hold on just camera adds a
couple hundred pounds how many cameras
were on him yeah i'm just one person is
how he starts that
like well you look like
that's not what the airline says
is he sitting closer to the camera no
he's sitting farther away than jack
this is one of these optical this is one
of these angle illusions that we're
doing i'm just one person but what
you're all so self-important
like he's batman i'm just one man yeah
i'm not the flabby super straight anchor
the city needs when it deserves they
bring up one of those like things with a
hole cut in for your head you go on
vacation
just a thinner guy
in scuba gear yeah he's just yeah it's
just holding a beach ball
so jack i'm just one do you want a
brunch so um when accused of defending
tucker carlson which is unforgivable
dorsey uh responded on twitter not
defending a thing holding up a mirror
and then he followed up with this doozy
which i think is important he said i
know this from being on the streets of
ferguson during the protests and
watching them meaning cnn trying to
create conflict and film it causing the
protesters to chant
fcnn and for those of you who don't
remember we ran this on the show here
are the protesters and i remember
laughing when it happened because i was
saying well what did you think was going
to happen cnn of course they're going to
turn on you
here's the video of that actually
happening
[Applause]
i'm an ally
his heart is breaking
his
soul is being crushed live
i know it'll solve it
cnn plus ah yes yes eight years from now
that'll go down in flames should pay for
this more yes
yes that's the problem that we have wait
no wait our ratings are in the tank it's
because people aren't paying enough
they don't hate us they love what if we
made it to us more expensive
[Laughter]
and by the way this is something to uh
token on you can have this right this is
the thing that bothers me most about
brian stelton we've talked about this
the reason cnn plus doesn't work the
reason disney is
it's is because when when these
corporate overlords aren't telling you
what you're supposed to watch
it doesn't work and so these people then
reach out and try and ingratiate
themselves now to the new corporate
overlords namely five companies who run
new media case in point if you have
never watched brian stelter and that's
all of you on his show uh he has this
sort of rotating banner behind him and i
don't know why it just is free
advertising for every social media
company this is what he does every show
[Music]
most of the time here on cnn we look
outward and focus on the world's stories
but here we carve out a little time to
look inward at the roles of the media
and how the media is going to change
watch it's a tradition that began 30
years ago this year 30 years ago
reliable it doesn't even say brian
delter's instagram no it's just welcome
yeah
think about that for a second why do
that i just walked here from my dressing
room and bore my feet tired
my bunions oh my god i need a knife when
you get to the corns file it now here's
their fruit think about this for a
second think of how scary this is a guy
simply that's trying to say i'm an ally
i'm an ally i'm an ally like a
lighthouse please twitter please youtube
please cnn please sorry cnn please
instagram please amazon it just
constantly rotates and shows
the world's most powerful companies to
try and prove his allegiance to try and
swear his loyalty these people are
cowards and again i judge them by their
behavior
not their bmi the behavior
is
has brian stelter has anderson cooper
has don lemon has chris have they ever
taken an opinion have they ever held a
stance genuinely can comment below
because i can't think of any and there
can be some like i know bill maher has i
know jon stewart has in the past
have any of the cnn line-up uh hosts
ever taken a stance that might get them
in trouble with the companies that he
just flashed across that screen
i'm judging them by their behavior
judging them by their actions right the
media the job was supposed to be to look
out for the interests of the people to
speak truth to power to hold power
accountable
well right now the power
is only a handful of companies and these
are the companies that are getting free
advertising i guess in brian's teleshow
you know they're not paying for that you
know they didn't ask for that that's him
going like look i'm giving this to you
for free please give me something
feature me this is a this is a
talentless person who simply acquiesces
to the most powerful people in power and
then they try and act that they are they
try and act like they are just like you
that's what's terrifying what's so scary
about this and we've seen this happen
with us on youtube that's why there's
there's nothing i would prefer more more
than you guys going over to mug club or
at least rumble for the free show yeah
because youtube has constantly changed
the rules and if you think of what
youtube has done
for a second for those of you who don't
know uh is it okay if i give people a
little bit of a history briefly here on
youtube because i've been there since
2006. my brother was one of the first
partners ever
so this is back in 2006 we did a video
called best impressions ever and back
then it was it would have been
considered viral and then i've been on
youtube myself since 2009.
back in the day in youtube and think of
the name it was what youtube the whole
idea was it was supposed to be about you
back then you didn't have any corporate
media on youtube it was people uploading
things sharing it with their family and
then some people realized that it could
be a valuable medium to upload comedy to
upload sketches news shows so it sort of
started developing but it was always
designed to develop its own ecosystem
and independent content that's how they
sold it and that's how they specifically
sold it to creators like me and made us
partners right hey you can make a living
creating content independently you don't
have to be a part of a news network you
don't have to be a part of a
of a cable network and people say great
so the these people i mean the
independent contact creator con 10
creators yourself included built up
youtube then they changed the algorithms
once upon a time youtube if you go back
and you look they used to actually have
a trending page that was based on what
was most popular
right the tabs existed trending or most
viewed most commented that's how this
channel initially grew because there was
controversy i was the only conservative
in 2008 2009 really on youtube and
people would comment and argue and so it
gets the top and most commented and
guess what that gave me an opportunity
to be in a level playing field and
people could see the content then
eventually enough of you guys out there
saw it and said hey you know what i
actually agree with this guy or i don't
agree with him but i like what he has to
say and i want to diversify my
my points of view youtube changed that
now there's no more trending there's no
more top commenting it's just sort of
veiled and they decide to curate what is
most popular and trending okay so that
was a major change that hurt a lot of
independent content creators then they
said you know what we're going to change
the algorithm to favor
right uploading regularly every single
day that's really hard for independent
content creators to do right at this
point cnn is coming in abc nbc is coming
in who is that going to favor the
independent content creator who maybe
has one editor on staff and right now is
doing one show per week that used to be
the standard people always used to say
watch my new show tuesday or friday or
whatever that's what this show used to
be because that's all we could do
but abc
can upload five clips a day so it's not
like they're actually giving a leg up to
these big networks they're just creating
new algorithms to favor those people
then what happened right okay well at
least you had the like and the dislike
button and you still had comments and
then youtube said you know what
we're gonna get rid of the dislike
button because i didn't like what was
happening on these corporate media
channels and the white house channel now
again this isn't them
giving some kind of a subsidy although
they did actually produce a show with
vox
it's just them creating a new lay of the
land to favor these
legacy corporations and now you might
watch this and at the end god forbid
it'll play seth meyers
and so that is what has happened
consistently and it's terrifying when
you think that they're working
hand-in-hand with legacy media who are
failed this is like a bailout it's like
a bank bailout it's like an airline
bailout cnn you deserve to fail
you deserve to fail disney you deserve
to fail netflix you deserve to fail
the problem is instead of the government
you have even more powerful entities now
in social media who effectively bail out
these companies and say don't worry
we'll eliminate the competition that has
been causing you to fail we'll get rid
of the channels that are out
performing you or will at least make it
so that they can no longer compete with
you it ends up being a bailout when
brian stelter anderson cooper don lemon
when the market speaks they always
fail
and so they group together and you see
it brian shelter's just dumb enough to
say the smart part out loud where he's
going i'm ingratiating myself to these
new media companies so that that way
please that way what please kill me last
and they will
when cnn fails though he'll be like i
was the best at cnn hire me
right
you can't even say that
i don't think he's going to be a mature
dear red lobster i was aggressively
mediocre at cnn hi yeah did you guys
like that
you can pay me and cheese it i don't
so that's my this is this is what's
scary about it is you're going to see
these people trying to consolidate more
and more power uh and once upon a time
new media back then it was referred to
as new media now it's mainly social
media the beauty was that there was no
gatekeeper right there's no barrier
entry now they've become more exclusive
than ever and they're trying to find a
way to make sure that they maintain
these grips of power and even doing that
they're not doing as well as they should
be
everything we're going to say no we're
good man let's go to the group of people
who uh keep us yes from having to be
dependent on that yes let's do that you
guys can hey comment share like before
we we're going to play bad movie lines
and with this it's actually the whoopi
goldberg
we're not going to play the trailer here
all right what's the movie do we play
the trailer now uh i can check flash
we can get the trailer right do we have
the trailer uh i don't have it now all
right never mind
what's the name of the film theodore
theodore rex with whoopi goldberg child
we'll do it live we had a stunt we had a
stun t-rex and then i found out that
dinosaurs aren't still alive dino dna
all right so uh we love you if you're on
rumble and youtube go over to rumble but
right now mug club only we're about to
play bad movie lines youtube piss off
[Music]
bye